this this really isn't a talk about the
api itself
i will have a couple of introductory
pieces to it
but it's really about the the talk about
the internals of the data store
what tools we use to build it uh how we
organize data that kind of stuff
so what is it it's an open source
distributed time series metrics and
events database
we say all three because you can use it
for any one of those things
the key thing is it's for things that
are arranged
by time uh and essentially you can use
it as the backend data store for
a lot of analytic style workloads so
they could be operational analytics
they could be user analytics that kind
of stuff so
the data model of it is you have
databases uh then you have time series
which
can be roughly equated to like tables in
sql
but the difference is you could have
hundreds of thousands of time series
or millions of time series and you'd
never have that in sql right
you don't all you also don't have to
define them
ahead of time it's not like you have a
schema where you say
these time series exist and these are
their columns
it just gets defined as you write the
data in
so then you have points which are kind
of like rows
but the difference is it's more column
oriented we don't store
null values so if you have a time series
where you have like say
30 columns but on most time you're only
writing in like three of those values
it doesn't waste extra like hard drive
space keeping null values on disk
so the primary api to this thing is all
http based
uh you can do a post to this endpoint
you specify the database name in it
uh you specify a username and password
either in the query parameters or in
basic auth
and then you give it a json blob which
is just a collection of objects
uh we'll dive into that in a second
queries are
a get against this endpoint and you pass
it in this
you know username password and this q
equals and it's some
string so we have a query language
that's specifically designed for this
so here's what the data looks like you
have
a collection of objects so here we have
a single series
called cpu it has three columns
time value and host and there we have
two points that we can see
organized in time descending
from this we can see time is there time
is actually a special built-in column
that's always there even if you don't
specify a time a time will be
written in for you because that's how
it's indexed
you can have double values integers
or strings or booleans
so here we're feeding in data and we're
not specifying
specifying a timestamp it actually gets
specified for you
come on in um
so the the other thing to note here is
that you don't even necessarily have to
have
like double values in a time series most
people when they think of time series
they think of uh
discrete measurements at intervals of
time uh like 10
seconds or a minute or whatever and it's
really always just like a value so it
would be like
your response time or your average cpu
load or
uh or a temperature or if you have like
external sensor data or whatever
in this you could just be feeding in
strings and counting those things later
so here's the the query language we
designed is
it's kind of like sql uh we we thought
that would be easier for people to
understand
is like a sql style query language it's
not exactly sql
it's a subset plus some extra stuff so
here we're grabbing
all the columns from some series
for all the points for the last hour
uh we have a lot of built-in aggregate
functions
i'm not going to go i don't have
examples of all of them but
really quickly it's min max
mean standard deviation histogram
percentiles
derivative uh a few others like first
and last
so in this example we're grabbing the
90th percentile values from some series
in 10 minute buckets for the last day
so what we get out of this is
six times 24 points discrete points in
at demarcated at 10 minute intervals and
those would be the 90th percentile
values
you can select from multiple series at
the same time
by selecting from a regular expression
so any series name
that matches that regular expression
will be included so here we're just
grabbing
the most recent data point from every
series that matches stats.cpu
you can also have string values as the
columns
so that that makes for that makes it so
you can do interesting things with like
you can feed your logs into this and log
lines into it
and you can do things like oh let's look
at the log lines for
this day and look for error and it will
just
grip through if you had like one data
point per log line
it would just like grab through all
those points and return the points that
match that
then the the last bit i'm going to cover
just like the basic
before i dig into the internals is
something we'll call continuous queries
so continuous queries are how we
do optimization we're only indexing
things by the
series and the timestamp so there are no
secondary indexes
if you want to create additional time
series that are
faster to look up on you can use
this like fan out feature which
basically like denormalizes the data it
just creates duplicates of the data so
in this case
we have a series called events and we
have a column
called user id and what we're doing here
is we're creating
a separate time series for each unique
user id
so we still have the events time series
but as we
pump in data it will create separate
time series for each individual user
which makes it very efficient to look up
like the series for
any given user uh
so then the other thing continuous
queries are for are good for is for down
sampling and summary data
so in this example we have events say we
have page id
which is the thing we want to count so
it could be like the hits in one hour
increments
and we're doing it for each unique page
id
so basically that that keyword
into into tells the cluster that this is
going to be a continuous query it's
going to be something where
we're not running the query and
returning a result
it's we're taking this and we're running
it continually in the background
on the cluster i'll dig into the details
of how that actually works
in this case what we get is uh
for each unique page id we'd get a time
series called events.that page id
and there'd be a tick once an hour
for of the count for that for that hour
so you can pair that up with uh things
like the
selecting from a regex to just say like
create a standard where we know we're
gonna want
to have like the max value from any
series that begins with
stats in five minute increments fed into
we say max dot
colon series name so before this
bracket page id tells it to interpolate
whatever the column value is
into the resulting series name here
colon's series name interpolates
whatever the series was that selected
from
into the resulting series name okay so
now we're gonna get into like the
underlying details how
how we what things we use to put all
this together
so the query language is like it looks
like sql but it's not quite
we used uh flex and bison which are
tools that people use for
usually for for building compilers and
programming languages
we use them to build a lexer and a
parser for
for our query language um
the query processing code is like
totally custom we
wrote from scratch everything's written
in go um
except for obviously these things these
generate c
code which then we wrap in go
to to create like go objects for the for
the query stuff
um but we had to hand code all the
aggregate functions and all the
conditional logic and stuff like that
so okay now
how data is organized in influx db
so it's it's time series data um
and it's a distributed database so we
had to make a decision about
how you know how do we decide what data
lives where
and originally we had started with this
thing that was like
consistent hashing uh which is what
cassandra uses to decide where rows go
and it didn't really work well for our
use case for for time series data
so what we landed on instead was the
idea of a shard
so shard is a contiguous block of time
of data so here we have an id
we have a start time we have an end time
and we have a list of server ids
so each one of those server ids that has
the shard contains a full
copy of that shard so it's totally
redundant for this
particular block of time
uh so that has
interesting implications for how queries
work so right now we're going to work
through like
the the dumb example so we're going to
assume all the time series database
time series data in the database for a
given block of time
maps to a single shard now that's one
way to operate it
you can actually scale out in a
different way which i'll talk about in a
second but
here let's just say if we look up
a block of time we know that all the
data lives on this shard
so that chart is what we can query so if
we look at this query here which is
select the count of values from foo
sometime series
grouped by five minute intervals well
we didn't specify time so we pretty much
have to hit every single shard in the
database
to answer this query so
it's it's distributed so shards can live
on multiple servers
so say server a is the server that gets
the query
it distributes the query out to all the
shards now some of those shards could
live on server a but they could live on
other servers
and how it works is at the shard level
it computes that
that value locally so it runs through
the raw points computes count
and then sends the single tick for the
five minute interval
back to server a so those results get
streamed back to server a
which then collates them and puts them
in the right time order
and sends it back to the client um
what do you mean the key
uh well so you're selecting from a
specific time series
okay so this is poorly named in this
example but this is like
i called it foo i should have called it
like user events or
log lines or something like that so
that's the key that we're looking up
and you can do other things like you can
say where
some column equals x uh to
further filter down the query you can't
do joins like you do in a sql database
um it's really like think of it like
you have a stream of events and you can
run some sort of aggregate function
across the stream
and filter it based on different
conditions
so the implications for how this query
stuff works is
the shards are how we scale things out
more shards
on more servers means you get better
scalability in terms of
how many data point how many raw data
points you can churn through to do any
any query uh group by times
less than the shard interval gives you
data locality
here you see we're computing that count
locally and then sending
only the computed tick back up to the
server
so the other possibility the other
potential thing is that
because all these shards get queried in
parallel there's no guarantee on which
one returns first
so we could get all the old results
first
and then we'd have to buffer all those
in memory because when server a returns
a response to the client it has to
return them in the right time
order um so
if you do something on your query where
you specify a time
on it the query gets evaluated when it
comes in
to server a and we say oh we know this
time interval lives on this shard
so we'll just query this single shard
get the result
send it back to the side so it's much
more efficient to look up and
it's faster so
really we evaluate the query and hit
only the shards we need to answer it
so the thing about data locality uh
this query here we have select count a
value from vu
we don't specify a time interval at all
so we're just going from for
all time and the problem with that is
the way things are right now uh we are
not
we're not doing intermediate values for
for count like
this is definitely much more of a
problem with things like percentiles or
quantiles
um so server a will distribute that
query
but instead of computing like an
intermediate result they will just
stream all the raw data points
back to server a which then has to
compute the result and send it back
so it just means that all the raw data
is going to go over the network to the
server that
initially got the query
okay so
the the part i mentioned about um
shards being like all assuming all the
data for a given time interval is
every time series for for a shard that's
true in one configuration but you can
actually configure it to scale
out uh so here's the conf what the
configuration for the shard stuff looks
like
you have a duration of time you have
split
which is for any given duration how many
shards should we create
and you have a replication factor which
is for every shard
how many servers should it live on how
many how many servers should have a
copy of that shard
so replication factor is is this piece
it's the server ids
and that's how we achieve read
scalability right um
if you have 20 servers that have have a
copy of the shard
any one of those servers can answer a
query for that shard
now the split piece
really comes into play for for shard
creation so here's what the
what the pipeline looks like for when we
create a shard
we have this point that we're writing in
uh to server a
we check we we put it in a time bucket
and we say is there a shard for this
time bucket if not
then go create the shards now in the
example i had
we had a replication factor we had a
split sorry of three
so what that means is for this time
bucket we're going to create three
shards
that store all the data for that time
bucket
now the question becomes okay if we have
three shards for a time bucket how do we
know
what data is in which of those shards
right and here's here's how we figure
that out
we look up a time bucket and all this is
kind of it's
it's like configuration metadata that
every server in the cluster knows about
so we look up the time bucket we say oh
there are
n number of shards that have the data
for this bucket
now the naive algorithm or the the
default algorithm is the the for
else part which is
we do a hash of the database in the
series mod the number of shards
and that will get us the shard that has
that the data for that series for that
period
so what that means is you get you can be
sure
with that algorithm you can be sure that
all the data for a given series for a
specific window of time
lives on one chart so you can get data
locality out of that you can do
like quick aggregate functions across it
but
what that also means is for your hot
shards
like generally with time series data
unless you're doing a bulk load of
historical stuff
you have now as the the bucket of time
that is hot so you're writing to those
all the time
uh so if you have split of 10 but you
have a cluster
size of 100 servers at any given time
only 10 servers are actually actively
taking in the rights
and even worse for a specific series
it's always mapped to one server that's
actively taking in those rights or
two servers if you have a replication
factor of two but they're
both taking every single write so
we have a way to override that for time
series that have many many data points
like more than you'd want to write to a
single server
and that's this regular expression piece
which is this split random thing in the
config
basically it just means you have a
regular expression that you can specify
and whenever you're writing data in it
will look at the series name and
evaluate it against the regex
if it matches then it will just randomly
distribute the data
off to one of the shards in that time
bucket
so what that means is you get
you get really good right scalability um
for those at the cost of no data
locality when you're doing a query
when you're doing a query say you have a
certain window of time
split into three separate shards
any query against that window of time
will have to hit all three pull the data
over the network and then run the
computation before you can get an answer
and so one of the other things is that
all the servers know about all the other
shards they know about
what their windows of time are they know
about the which servers in the cluster
have those shards
uh but
it also means that those rules can
change
over time with time series data like old
historical data
it's generally cold so it's cold as far
as rights are concerned
it's hot for reads but it's cold for
right so you don't have to worry about
like splits and stuff like that
so if you start out and one server can
easily handle all the rights you're
dealing with
and then you start scaling up you can
change the split value later
and the whole thing will just work
because it knows
for these windows of time there was only
one chart and then for these later
windows of time there were
two and in
in a release that we're gonna do uh the
o60 release which we'll be pushing out
sometime this month
uh you'll be able to manually copy
shards from one server to another
which will give you a couple of things
one it'll make it easy to replace
down nodes like so if a node goes down
and it's just not coming back
you can spin up a new system in the
cluster and just
copy all the shards that it had from the
other nodes in the cluster
that has it but it also means
that you can dynamically update the
replication factor if you have a
specific window of time that's very very
hot
for your reads you can copy the shard
over to other servers so that many
servers can answer those queries
and then later on when when those become
cold you can actually delete it and
clear it out so we give you like the
tools like manually control
where data lives in the cluster it's
it's a lot
we give you a lot more knobs and and
tools to move around data than you would
get in like hbase or cassandra right
because everything in those are kind of
like
automatically mapped for you
uh so yeah okay
so i want to talk a little bit about the
the storage engine that we use
so each shard maps to
a level db instance level db is
an embedded database it's basically a
library
and it's an ordered key value hash
so we use that to basically
put in time series data we use the fact
that the key space is ordered
so that we can order sequences of points
so here's what our keys look like there
are 24 bytes
in three different eight byte segments
the id which is eight bytes and that
uniquely identifies
a database a series and a column
uh which means all the values for a
column
are in a contiguous block in the key
space
then there's time which is a microsecond
epic
it's we normalize it to be positive so
that
range scans work so again
all the all the values for a given
column
in their time are organized in in time
sequence
and then finally
there's a sequence number so
we added a sequence number in because
we wanted uh inflex db to be useful for
events data
and with events data you can have events
with the exact same timestamp
which you can't have in a round-robin
database like
graphite or rrd right uh so
sequence number is just a thing that we
use to make sure they don't
collide with each other uh it's a un-64.
the first three digits in the sequence
number are
an id that uniquely identifies the
server within the cluster
so it means that rights can come in to
any server in the cluster
and they're able to assign sequence
numbers to points
without coordinating with the other
servers to figure out
you know what's a unique sequence number
so under the covers here's like what the
what the
ordered key space might look like so
these are normally bytes but i'm showing
like
the integer values to make it more
readable
we have a point at top at the top that
we're writing in it has two columns in
it
so here we can see column one and column
two
the parts in green we see the time stamp
and the sequence number are the same
so that's actually the exact same point
in the two different column
keys
here the two that are adjacent to each
other have the same time stamp but a
different sequence number
so it's a different point but with the
same timestamp
the values are just bytes we use
protobuf
both for our intra-cluster communication
as a serialization protocol
and also for what we store in the
database
so here's like what a value looks like
you can see you can have a string
a double a boolean um
or an integer uh and the integers and
protobufs are variable length encoded so
if you're writing in a lot of ones or
twos or whatever
they take they don't take a full uh
64 bits and then the last one
is for us for inter intracluster
communication we don't actually store
nulls so if we see is null as true
we just throw it away we don't store it
so what are the implications of like
this underlying
storage schema it means aggregate
queries
do range scans for the entire time range
which you would expect on like
percentiles and stuff like that
you may not expect that on uh
counts or or like min or max whatever we
don't do any indexing on that kind of
stuff
so you whatever the the time range is
that you specify we scan over those
points where clauses
do a range scan for the entire range as
well so if you have some string value
and you're matching against this
and this other time range it's going to
scan all the points of that time range
to look for for points that match that
and so then the other piece is that
queries against multiple columns
will do multiple range scans you'll do a
range scan for every single column that
you're querying
so if you do something like select value
from
some series where tag
equals you know host a
it's actually going to scan through all
the points
it's going to do two scans one through
through tag and then one through the
through the actual values
so really what that means is that
if you want to get better performance
we're not doing range scans over a lot
of stuff
splitting things into many separate time
series are the way to get better
performance and the way to index things
uh also because of the way the sequence
numbers are
there's a hard cap you can't have any
more than 999
servers within a cluster so
to have a big cluster of servers
doing all that communication for
multiple raft groups
seems like it would be very problematic
and the raft implementation we worked
with we're working with
doesn't have any of that built in it
doesn't have like the idea of like raft
groups
there's really just the cluster
so this is what it looks like when a
server joins cluster
if you have one server you start it up
and you have other servers that
you can point to any server in a cluster
through this seed servers configuration
option
they start up they connect via raft and
they say hey i want to join
if this if the server they connected to
isn't the leader they get redirected to
the leader
they join the cluster and then they get
all the log data replayed to them
from the leader and the leader also
tells all the other servers hey
this server joined so then they all
connect to the new server and the new
server all connects to all of them
via tcp so our
our tcp protocol is
it's protobuf based so every server has
a connection to every other server in
the cluster
and we we multiplexed the request
responses
onto this single connection we don't do
a thing where like we have connection
pools and we
we do like request response request
response
we just pipe requests in and read
responses uh out
on a separate thread and use ids to map
them back together
so this tcp protocol is what we use for
the distributed queries
that's what we use for writes
here's what the request object looks
like so this is a protobuf definition
you can use this and generate a file
which is basically
what you can use to parse the the bytes
the binary bytes or generate the bytes
for
a request and there we can see we have a
write we have a query
and we have heartbeats so we send
heartbeats through to make sure
so that the servers know what other
servers are up in the cluster so that
when a query comes in
they can route that query to a server
that's
up and able to handle it
uh here's what a response looks like we
have a query
we have a write-okay we have the
heartbeat
explain query so for any query that you
can issue you can put explain in front
of it and it will give you information
about
uh what shards were hit how many data
points it ran through and how long
each of those took to return and then
finally the the end stream one which is
important because
as i mentioned some of the queries like
you're piping raw data back
like the raw data points back to the
server that has to run the computation
uh if you do a query where you're
reading in like a billion data points
you don't want to put that into a single
response
so we it's a streaming protocol where
you do chunks
and it can compute the chunks as they
come in and the end stream just says hey
i'm done i'm not sending you any more
data
so the right's going over the the tcp
protocol
the real question is like how do we
ensure replication how do we sure
ensure that they actually succeed for
this we have a right ahead log
which is like most databases have this
pretty much all
and the idea is that
it ensures that you can you can you can
have a
durable operation right so a write comes
into server a
we log it to the wall and then we send a
success back to the client immediately
and then what we do
is we send it to the places that needs
to get written to
it could be a local shard it could be
a remote server it could be 10 remote
servers if your replication factor is
very high
with each one of those rights as it
finishes it writes a commit message
into the wall once all of the
the people who are supposed to get the
right have committed then the wall knows
they can at that point truncate
and get rid of the old data so
really what we're using the wall for is
to to deal with
failures so if a server goes down or it
starts
if it gets starts getting slow um
we need to be able to protect against
that we need to be able to
just spool those rights to disk and then
when it comes back
up replay them from our last known
commit
which means that we don't we don't need
to buffer all the rights in memory
so one of the things like when you're
dealing with distributed systems
and you're dealing with like rights and
stuff like that you can have a problem
where
one server can go down and another
server that's like
buffering rights to that server just
backs up and backs up until you fill up
all your memory
and then you get like a cascading
failure because they're all just like
waiting for this one other server to
come
come back up in this case they'll just
send it to disk and then when that
server comes up they'll replay off disk
onto that server
and then the other nice thing is that
with the wall we don't have to write
into level db directly
so level db is log structured merge tree
which means there are sometimes delays
when you're running a compaction
in the database so it can cause your
worst case performance to be you know
really bad you can get like a couple
second delay
with this if you have a big enough right
buffer
um it means actually it doesn't matter
like what your right buffer size is
it it won't block like your your worst
case performance is still going to be
pretty good
because it's just spooling the data to
disk and immediately returning a
response
does that mean that your data is not
available for query until it's
actually moved the question was does
this mean
your data isn't available for query
until it's actually been moved into
leveldb
the answer is yes in practice
that is instant it's like very very
quick
um it's sub millisecond um
unless you're having problems with the
server that you're writing data into
okay so this is this last bit of like
internal pieces uh
so continuous query as i mentioned it's
for it's for denormalization
for duplicating data to get better query
performance it's for down sampling
uh they're distributed and all the data
is replicated through raft
so what that looks like is if you create
a query a continuous query
it doesn't run like it just creates it
in raft
which gets replicated replicated out to
all the other servers
now raft is a consensus protocol so
nothing will get committed until all
until
a quorum of the servers have committed
that
but it also means that if you have some
servers that are misbehaving
they could not get your continuous query
right away
which really for fan out queries that's
the only thing you have to worry about
so
this is like again the fan out query
where you say oh we're going to take
this event series
we're going to create many other series
based off the specific users
so looking at the right pipeline again
we need to go back and update this with
continuous queries in mind
so here's what it looks like actually
with continuous queries which is
you write the data server a it logs to
the wall returns success
and then we evaluate fanouts and then
everything gets committed
so under underneath this is what a
fanout might look like
yup oh no uh
so here we have a foo metric
um some some value that we're writing in
uh we have a time a sequence number a
value and a host
in the fanout we're creating a separate
time series per
host value
and what we can see there from the spot
highlighted in green
is that the time and the sequence number
of the fanned out point are exactly the
same as the source point
which is nice for a couple of reasons
it means that when you have fan out
points
you and you if you know what the source
series was
you can look up the source point so if
you're only
if you're fanning out but you're only
keeping like one of the columns
and maybe the source series has like 20
with a bunch of extra data
you can then query that point directly
and querying any individual point is
very efficient it's just a key lookup
because it knows the id the time the
sequence number which is the key that
we're looking for
but it also means that failures in the
middle of a fan
out are fine so if a write comes in
we log it to the wall and we say we have
like three fan outs we were supposed to
do on this particular right
and it did one of them and then it
failed
when the server and the server died when
the server comes back up
and it replays from the from the commit
log from the wall
it's fine that it rewrites those
previous points
that it had fanned out because it just
updates them in place
because we're setting the time the
sequence number we're not assigning like
new sequence numbers to fanouts
uh okay now the summaries which work a
little bit differently
so we call them continuous queries
but the truth is for the for the summary
stuff
they don't run all the time in the
background it's more like
they check occasionally whether or not
they have to run
and actually it's the raf leader in the
cluster
that does this check so every second it
just says hey do i have any continuous
queries to run
and it keeps track the the raft metadata
that gets
replicated to all the other servers they
keep track of
when the last successful run of
continuous queries was
so they run those queries then they mark
the time which gets replicated through
raft and then you keep going
so here's what that looks like we have a
continuous query at the top
where we're grabbing the counts in one
hour
buckets of each unique page id
so basically every hour on the hour
it will run this query and it will add a
where time to the query to scope it by
the last hour of data now you can
actually configure
when how far behind these continuous
queries lag
so sometimes you know your your data
collection
lags behind by like five minutes or
whatever you could say
don't compute the the continuous query
data for this until like 10 minutes past
whatever the time range was
uh so here we see we have a fan fanout
and
it assigns a time which is the the
bucket time and a sequence number
and for the sequence numbers for
downsampled
data we actually start with the sequence
number of one
and go up from there we don't have that
unique server id thing because
we always know that it's being run on
the leader
there's one server running it what that
means is
all this continuous query stuff the down
sampling stuff is fault tolerant
across like server failures if the
leader dies
in the middle of a run a new leader will
get elected
and it'll just pick up from the last
point that it was run if the continuous
query run had gotten halfway through
it'll end up recalculating those but
it'll just overwrite the previous values
it's not like you'll get like duplicate
values or anything like that
uh yeah all right so one
last little thing which is something
we're working on right now
uh well not yet we'll be working on in
about a week or so
i'm curious what people think of it is
custom functions which is
the idea that we're we're going to use
javascript for this so essentially
you'll be able to go in
write some javascript code that will get
some points
and then emit some points give it a name
and then create that it'll use raft to
replicate the function across the
cluster
and then at that point you can issue a
query where you call out to your custom
function
uh from whatever um
the there are some things that i think
are pretty cool about this
since it's javascript you can do
whatever you want like you can run
custom calculations
but you could also do things like
trigger a web hook or something like
that
so if you pair custom functions up with
continuous queries
you can monitor your data either in real
time or
every minute or every hour or whatever
using this custom functions you can do
like you can build monitoring
into the database
and then the last piece is pub sub which
is
for this we'll have to do we we've had
long had
an issue open on github where we needed
we wanted to do a binary protocol
we started with http because we thought
it would be easiest for people to use
and get started with
but binary like for anything that's very
high traffic we need binary
a binary an efficient binary protocol
and
pub sub is going to be one of those
things that needs this so
the idea is you can run any type of
query
and you say into subscription
parentheses so say you connect to one
server
you issue this query it uses raf to
replicate this information across the
cluster
so that whenever a write comes in to any
server in the cluster
it evaluates this query and says oh this
client is waiting for it
sends it back to the server which then
sends it back to the client
now the other piece is you can do pair
that up with group by time intervals
so in this case we have like group by
time one minute
so what would happen is this server has
that there's a client connected to this
server that has that subscription
he gets the data as it comes in and once
a minute it will just send a tick
back to the client with that information
that's all i have
so are there other questions um
i guess the window size on charts yes
so the question sorry the question was
uh
can you dynamically change the window
size of the shards
uh and the answer is yes uh so there's
actually an endpoint
in the api where you can create shards
so right now shards get created under
the covers automatically on an
as needed basis so if there is no shard
existing for a given time bucket that
you're writing into
it will get creative for you there's
nothing to stop you
from creating them ahead of time and
when you create a shard you can specify
a start time
and end time and which server should
have a copy of it
so you can manually configure like if
you know like you have a certain
server configuration you want these
shards to be here these shards to be
here
uh we will be adding tools later on to
do things like collapse shards together
and stuff like that so if you wanted
it's that's useful for cold data
particularly like
where you're not actively writing into
that that time range
it's nice um yeah sorry was there
another
static themselves or like the bucket
like
can that time buckets too
so the question is of the time range is
static themselves the for the bucket
or can they be resized right now um
i mean nothing right now for existing
shards they can't be resized
like whatever their time range is that's
what it is but if you
change the duration like say you start
out with like
seven day shards and you're just writing
in a ton of data and you're like okay
we're gonna go down to one day shards
the next time if you're writing in only
new data
the next time you get to the point where
it rolls over it would create a shard
size of
a day same same thing if you updated the
split value
if you had started off with one and
later you changed it to like five
when it creates the new shard it will it
or the new bucket it will create five
shards for that for that bucket of
does it impact the creativity of data
before the change happened
no uh so when a query comes in
it's evaluated against what the actual
shards
are and it says okay i it will it will
impact
if you so if you had like a shard size
of
a day and then you suddenly like dropped
down to a shard size of an hour
and you had a bunch of queries running
where you were doing group by time
intervals of like four hours
you would lose data locality
so you could potentially affect your
your read
your query performance by going to
smaller shard sizes where you have a
bunch of queries that are
that cross that boundary yeah
all right uh i think that's it thanks
everyone